There's a saying in Kishi no Ma that once you
lose a military battle, you're just another man,
but if I lose, I'm trash. That's
okay. That's what my parents always told me.
[Music] That's why
I aim to become a professional knight.  Ever since that day, I
have decided that if I lose in the military council, I will die.
But if that happens, there is a problem. The
moment I lose, I am trash, and I
have to hand over the trash to the water transport master.
This is already a big problem.  I don't care if it's rude.
Is there anything you want when the measure wins?
[Music] I haven't
really thought about anything other than the military, so I
'll think about it after I buy it. I
don't think it's good or scary.
[Music]  [Laughter] It's the world that was not
prepared enough to take their own lives. They didn't expect the
lives of the world to be what they wanted when the measure won. They
don't even meditate like Mr. Zosui. They don't
even make light of that.  I know this is my own
problem. I'm not
going to bet on it. I'm going to make a
stupid mistake.
[Music]
Now I'll forgive you.